normally sedate uruguayans protest
by banging pots and pans they blame the
government for allowing uruguay to
transit
from a success story to the country with
the highest per capita
infection rate in the world and in just
a few weeks
the small south american country which
is sandwiched between argentina and
brazil
had been hailed as the exception in a
region of pandemic turmoil
but now the bubble has burst
we must take care of ourselves those who
don't get vaccinated will die
it's simple they're going to die if they
get infected they die
with a population of only 3.5 million
uruguay is seeing more than 3 000
infections per day
by far the highest per capita in the
world
and also the fifth highest death rate
the government has
never ordered lockdowns or enforced
other measures
calling it a matter of principle but
this has led to a blase attitude among
citizens
even though health experts warned that
the more contagious variant of the virus
from neighboring brazil
would infect them quickly
until the dead or you're dead you will
think whatever you want
until it happens in your family it's
difficult for people to become aware
the latest wave of covid is breaking new
records every day in latin america
in colombia deaths are surpassing more
than 420 daily
el quinlego hopes his wife won't be one
of them
as she waits for an icu bed at this
medellin hospital
a great sense of helplessness because
what can you do as a human being
you can't do anything the pan-american
health organization says no region has
been harder hit
more than three million people have
lost their lives to close it
and nearly half of these deaths happened
right here in the americas
back in uruguay hospitals are running
out of sedatives needed for using
respirators in critical care units
a painful reminder that in this pandemic
overconfidence is a dangerous thing
lucia newman al jazeera